the economy is in the gutter gas is
through the roof the store shelves are
empty violent crime is skyrocketing our
money is rapidly losing value we're
prohibited from participating in much of
society without injecting ourselves with
an experimental drug and even when we do
inject ourselves with that experimental
drug much of our country remains closed
all on joe biden's watch
most of it at his direction
which is why the president who has an
anvil of an approval rating at the
moment has enlisted one of america's
most likable celebrities to convince the
country that everything is going great
if only we're brave enough brave enough
to live through two of the most
difficult years many of us can remember
brave enough to pull ourselves up again
and again
america is the home of the brave it's
why we keep getting up no matter how
many times we get knocked down
like with our economy it isn't all the
way back but it's getting stronger we
may be entering year three of a pandemic
none of us wanted or expected we are
stronger than we were a year ago today
we're bringing on new drivers
we're expanding the fear that was there
is going away business is booming we're
strong we are courageous
we are resilient we are america land of
the brave
i've long said it's never been a good
bet to bet against america
and that's more true today than ever
forget for a moment how pathetic it is
that the president needs to enlist woody
from toy story to make people like him
did you notice the subtle transformation
of language
he said tom hanks said that america is
the land of the brave
that's not the line
traditionally we say that america is the
land of the free and the home of the
brave but we can't say that anymore
because in biden's america the first
part is no longer true i'm michael
knowles is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from joseph campise
who says
i'm glad we agree kids are resilient now
we can all stop worrying that they'll
get the sniffles you know because
they're so resilient great point great
point when the liberals like new york's
democrat governor kathy hokel say hey
don't worry about us masking up kids
constantly and forcing them to take this
experimental drug and kicking them out
of schools and taking them away from
their friends and family for
two years and and counting don't worry
kids are resilient you say oh kids are
resilient i guess they can handle the
cold
i guess they can handle a mild cough i
guess that'll be just fine especially if
they get a good night's sleep when you
want a good night's sleep i would
recommend you check out bowlin branch no
one wants to cut corners on what's
important and few things matter more
than a good night's rest bowlin branch's
signature sheets feel so soft and light
you'll forget you're not actually
sleeping on a cloud and they're
sustainably made for uncompromising
quality from field to factory i
absolutely love bowling branch i have
been using them for
years
the only reason i didn't want to upgrade
my bed from a queen to a king was i was
afraid i wouldn't get more bolin branch
sheets and then i just did i just
they're just so wonderful they're a
great i've bought
many
versions of the bowling brand sheets
their signature hemmed sheets from
bowling branch are a best seller for a
reason
buttery soft lightweight organic cotton
in a classic sateen weave for sheets
that not only start out soft they get
softer over time
they're really terrific 100 organic
cotton 30 day risk free trial free
shipping and returns experience the best
sheets you've ever felt at
bowlingbranch.com get 15 off your first
set of sheets when you use promo code
michael at checkout that's bowlin branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch dot com promo code
michael
i don't think i'm reading too much into
that tom hanks video to say
that the decision to change land of the
free and home of the brave to simply
land of the brave
was intentional
when you are talking about any
television commercial first of all but
certainly when you're talking about a
political television commercial
certainly when you're talking about one
that involves the president of the
united states
every single
word every single syllable is
intentional
and the reason that you don't hear any
anything about freedom in that in that
commercial is because it would be
preposterous
it's not even that joe biden and tom
hanks wouldn't want to be able to claim
that we are more free today than ever it
would just be laughable it would totally
take you out of the commercial because
we look around and we say we're not free
at all some of our most basic rights
that we previously had have been taken
away from us and remain in the hands of
the doctor vouchers of the world we're
talking about personal freedoms we're
talking about political freedoms right
not only that we can't go run our
businesses not only that we can't walk
into a restaurant now in many places
without showing our medical history but
our our political freedoms too we we are
not even entitled to act through our
legislatures very often
because when our when our senators for
instance go out
and they say we disapprove of this joe
biden osha mandate well dr fauci says
who cares and the head of osha says who
cares and the bureaucrats say who cares
and then we've got to rely on the
supreme court to hopefully overturn some
of them but not but not all of them
we're we are less free
and
if if you haven't learned by now that
the left uses the manipulation of
language as its primary means of
changing the culture
i can't help you i can't help you we've
had over half a century of political
correctness wokeness that's what they're
doing and it's a it's a terrifying
subtle admission from biden that we are
in fact less free now
that's biden's approach to dealing with
his failed policies is just to pretend
that everything is good to pretend that
you're an idiot to pretend that you
don't have eyes that you can't see
what's going on to get america's
famously most likeable celebrity to go
out and say no it's really good the
economy is really good you're doing
great everyone's happy be happy be happy
that's the biden approach the complete
denial of reality gavin newsom in
california has taken the opposite
approach to deal with his failed
policies california is falling apart my
old city of los angeles is really
falling apart you've got crime through
the roof you've got
stores rather boarded up buildings
boarded up you've got now railroads
railway stations that are getting robbed
and looted every single night by
criminals that the city and the state do
nothing about when you go to downtown
when you go to skid row it is it is not
just like a third world country it's
much worse than a third world country
and that's exactly the point that gavin
newsom made when he went to visit
let me thank everybody behind me but as
uh said let me in particular thank all
the men and women in orange and yellow
for their outstanding work and for uh
moving quickly i mean just uh it was
less than 48 hours ago we said we're
coming down uh let's set this thing up
uh we had all the lawyers say well hold
on it's not your property
if you get injured i mean all you know
every conceivable thing that makes you
frustrated and crazy about government
bureaucracy was it played but everybody
worked together they worked through
those issues we got this memorandum of
understanding uh and we created a new
framework of understanding about our
mutual responsibility to address what
the hell's going on here
and i say that with emphasis
i see what you see i see what you've
been covering i see what everybody's
seeing asking myself what the hell is
going on
i mean look like a third world country
these images the drone images that were
on the nightly news day in and day out
some networks weaponizing them for their
own you know political agenda and others
just reporting the damn news
fairly
and appropriately what the hell's going
on here in california what who the hell
is the governor in this place what the
hell kind of policies have you guys been
allowed oh me it's me i'm oh it's all my
policies oh whoops
but yeah someone should vote that guy
out that me that gavin newsom it's like
a third world country here
the only reason i disagree with gavin
newsom's assessment is that it's not
like a third world country it is
significantly worse than a third world
country
there are some poor countries that get
along basically just fine and they've
got decent cohesion and they don't have
crime that's skyrocketing through the
roof
la is much worse than that there's very
little cohesion the rule of law is
collapsing and frankly even the da's
even the prosecutors are are not
enforcing the law and then
you you've got crime everywhere and
people living in filth
and and it's it's even worse when it's
in a rich place a really rich city
a really rich state
one of the largest economies in the
world it's just california
says what the hell is going on
it is newsom's fault it's not entirely
newsome's fault but it's partially
newsome's fault
and it's certainly the part fault of his
party
and the democrat mayor
mayors and the democrat prosecutors
and the democrat state representatives
and that's been going on for a long time
and so what newsom is trying to do is
evade responsibility he says there's no
way that i'm going to be able to
convince angelino's and other
californians to look at skid row to look
at the railroad yards and and tell them
everything's tickety-boo so that because
that's not going to work i'm just going
to come out on the other side and i'm
just going to start yelling about it the
the thing i find most interesting about
this story though
is that what gavin newsom has done here
is is exactly what donald trump did
with regard to immigration that got him
in so much trouble
do you do you remember
i know is way way back a few years ago
donald trump said why
are we why do we have these virtually
open borders with excrement whole
countries said these are s-h-i-t whole
countries
and he they said how dare you say that
how dare you disparage these countries
and say that they're filthy and
ridden with crime
and then gavin newsom just did exactly
the same thing he said this railyard is
filthy it's ridden with crime
it's just like a third world country
they said exactly the same thing
and it's not the only
democrats
question the results of elections
they've been doing it for decades now
that's totally fine that's actually good
that's a defensive democracy donald
trump questions the result of the
strangest election in our history
certainly the strangest one in recent
history that's terrible that's a threat
to democracy and you especially see it
with
the rhetoric forget about gavin newsom
the rhetoric coming from
the current occupant of the oval office
who among other terrible things has
overseen a huge rise in gas prices which
you can get a little relief from if you
check out get upside are you spending
too much money on gas
yes you are i know that i don't i may
not have spoken to you about it
personally but i know if you're living
in america right now you're spending too
much on gas what if i told you you could
get up to 25 cents cash back for every
gallon of gas you put in your car that's
actually that's not true i want to be
totally honest here
you can actually get up to 50 cents per
gallon cashback on your first tank when
you use promo code knowles with the get
upside app it's a free app you go to the
google play app store you go to the
apple app store wherever you get your
apps you download the free get upside
app
use that promo code knowles get up to 50
cents per gallon cash back on your first
tank the cash back is super easy to get
it goes straight into your bank account
or it goes to paypal if you prefer or to
an amazon gift card or a gift card to
some other shop
people are driving a lot or saving as
much as two to three hundred dollars
per
a year on this it's pretty unbelievable
head on over right now to get upside
that is the free get upside app
code knowles
save up to 50 cents per gallon on your
first tank
joe biden
nice old uncle joe
the mature
respectful
responsible adult in the room
nice guy
the return to normal
was just asked a totally fair question
about immigration
by peter ducey member of the
white house press pool
and and joe biden
got caught on microphone
calling him a very naughty name
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound
more inflation you're going to ask me
about more inflation you you dirty
rotten journalist you scum of the earth
you you you're slime you're the enemy of
the people you how dare you ask me a
totally fair question you stupid son of
a gun he didn't say son of a gun he was
nastier than that
first takeaway joe biden is a mean and
nasty and small man and he always has
been and the idea that he's this nice
warm guy who licks ice cream cones and
pats little kids on the head is a media
contrivance he's a jerk he's a mean
nasty shallow jerk don't forget what he
did to corn pop poor corn pop over there
at the delaware swimming pool and joe
biden was really mean and nasty to him
and he's been mean and nasty for his
whole career
he was willing to let
clarence thomas
be smeared dragged through the mud on
bogus charges a high-tech lynching he
was happy to do it
until clarence thomas acknowledged that
called him out on that at his hearing
finally joe biden relented joe biden who
said that mitt romney wants to put black
people back in chains joe biden
who
a petulant
stupid uneducated man at a presidential
debate
interjecting whenever donald trump would
make a point say you're racist you're
racist you're you're you're you're mean
you're racist
racism is what's the worst thing you
could call somebody in the country
racist he keeps doing it smeared a 17
year old kid kyle rittenhouse call in a
presidential campaign ad said he was
said he was a racist because it's the
worst thing that you can call somebody
in america today
launched his presidential campaign on
the lie that donald trump called
neo-nazis fine people at charlottesville
he's just a he's just a dirty rotten
nasty ugly man i don't i don't know how
else to put it
and he says this sort of thing about
peter ducey now
i like peter ducey but
journalists can take it i don't i don't
mind it when politicians go a little
hard after journalists my only problem
here
is the double standard donald trump
calls the press the enemy of the people
and you you see commercials
as though as though the journalists are
little orphan children with sarah
mclaughlin playing in the background you
know you've got don lemon and chris
cuomo in the arms of the angel you know
like these these poor little babes where
if you besmirch their high honor you
know at cnn that somehow you're
threatening our constitution but then
this
jerk gets asked a completely fair
question about why inflation is going
through the roof historic decades high
inflation said you stupid son how dare
you ask me about why are you doing this
but i guess i guess one of the reasons
why joe biden is
so on edge right now
other than his
uh
manifest senility is that right now
we may see war break out in ukraine we
might see a russian invasion of ukraine
and we might be involved in that war
joe biden according to reports
is considering sending several thousand
us troops
over to ukraine joe biden has ordered
the families of embassy personnel in
ukraine to leave the country
to return home
he's considering sending warships and
aircraft
and then actually we found out from the
pentagon yesterday it's not just going
to be several thousand troops
who could be deployed the numbers as
high as 8 500.
as you're all aware the united states is
deeply concerned about the current
situation in europe
we remain
keenly focused on russia's unusual
military activities near the ukrainian
border including in belarus
and consulting extensively with our
transatlantic allies and partners the
department continues to support
diplomatic efforts to de-escalate the
situation
now as the president has said
even as we continue to prioritize
diplomacy and dialogue we must also
increase readiness
secretary austin has placed a range of
units in the united states on a
heightened preparedness to deploy which
increases our readiness to provide
forces if nato should activate the nrf
or if other situations develop
all told
the number of forces that the secretary
has placed on heightened alert
comes up to about 8 500 personnel
in the event of nato's activation of the
nrf or a deteriorating security
environment the united states would be
in a position to rapidly deploy
additional brigade combat teams so this
is pretty serious and i'm not i'm not
sure that this is just a bluff from the
biden administration this this seems to
be
this seems to be a little bit more
serious than that
and
the situation is rapidly deteriorating
there there seem to be two
schools of thought on this there seem to
be only two opinions that you're allowed
to have on the right when you look at
ukraine either you have to be a complete
isolationist non-interventionist there
is no reason ever to interfere in any
country if we are not directly at
existential risk
pull all the troops home from everywhere
in the world don't don't interfere
anywhere
that's on one hand and then on the other
hand
is the bush era neocon never met a
country they didn't want to bomb
intervene every single place in the
world for the vague expansion of
democracy and so that we can raise pride
flags in kandahar those are according to
our popular discourse the only two views
you're allowed to have
may i offer a third perspective here
this is my this is my third radical
perspective on ukraine and foreign
policy generally
foreign policy
is very complicated
that's my ambitious
shocking
analysis
do you care about ukraine
maybe you do
probably you don't
should we go to war with russia over
ukraine well what does war mean does
that mean we're going to invade moscow
probably not does it mean it doesn't
mean a land war even in ukraine i don't
know maybe does it mean
sanctions and air support i don't know
possibly
what is at stake what is the american
interest at stake in ukraine i'm not so
sure but i do know that before we went
to war in other countries within the
past decade we didn't really have a good
sense of what our interests were and
then very often we made things worse i'm
thinking of libya for instance do you
remember we had to go into libya why i
don't know because hillary clinton said
we did and it was very important to go
into libya and then what happened we got
rid of muammar qaddafi because he's a
bad he was a bad guy we got rid of
qaddafi and then what happened things in
libya got worse they didn't seem to get
all that much better what about syria we
were told we had to go in and get rid of
bashar assad in syria why did we have to
get rid of bashar assad well because
he's a bad guy okay he's a bad guy who's
the good guy who's going to take over
show me the good guy i don't see a lot
of good guys in fact bashar assad
his many sins notwithstanding actually
did a fairly decent job of killing
terrorists at least some of the time
what's our interest what do we really
want to see in syria do you remember
this is my favorite one there was a meme
going around the internet about 10 years
ago
coney 2012.
coney 2012 for those younger listeners
out there you won't remember this
this was the hot we all had to band
together to stop a warlord in africa
named joseph coney
because he did bad things i guess but no
and everyone got really riled up and we
had to go and let's go send in the 101st
airborne and and then what i don't know
we don't even know
i don't even know what happened to kony
foreign policy is very very complicated
ukraine
is one of the most conquered areas
in
the world
ukraine has been conquered by
russia
by zarist russia by
soviet russia
by the austro-hungarian empire by the
ottoman empire by the polish-lithuanian
commonwealth
poland one also one of the most
conquered territories in the history of
the world conquered ukraine ukraine
means
borderland
it derives from the slavic word for
borderland
it's going to be conquered again and and
then someone else is going to conquer it
and maybe it goes independent for a
while it's good it's
very
complicated and then furthermore there
is a a very real critique of american
adventurism that i think we need to keep
in mind which is
we we are not allowed to defend our own
border
we must it is an existential threat to
america if we do not defend the current
border of ukraine which has existed for
about five minutes
but we are not allowed to defend the
southern border of the united states
that you just can't do it it's not
possible
the courts won't let us
the activists won't let us
the global
elite won't let us the big business
interests won't let us can't do that
for whatever reason we the mightiest
military power in the history of the
world can't secure the rio grande but it
is of dire importance that we fly over
and send our ships over to ukraine to
prevent a potential russian incursion to
its traditional sphere of influence
you can't keep that up forever folks
either i am somewhat sympathetic to the
argument that we don't want russia to
encroach on ukraine that it's not good
for our interests to let russia move
further out
but empires cannot
neglect their homeland
to focus on far-flung holdings forever
you can't you can't do that forever if
you do not have some internal cohesion
if you do not have some sense of of the
national interests at stake if you do
not have a common understanding of what
a national interest even is and
certainly
if you don't have a common set of values
that you are allegedly
sending abroad
then it's very very difficult to project
influence we don't even know what that
influence would be
and so i the people who want to project
american imperial strength around the
world okay fine that's all well and good
but you can't do it by completely
neglecting the homeland forever and
that's why we're in a bind
in ukraine
it's not it's not safe it's not a very
safe situation when you want to keep
your household safe though i would
strongly recommend you check out
ring you all know about the ring video
doorbell by now here's something you
might not know ring makes an alarm ring
makes an award-winning alarm system
that's this great home security system
available with professional monitoring
best of all
you can easily install it yourself it's
simple to set up it's easy to use you
get all the sensors for motion doors and
windows that will work on any house or
apartment just like yours i love it ring
makes me feel so much safer especially
when i'm on the road knowing that sweet
little alisa and my cute little baby
june are protected
especially when we're all on the road
when i know that our home is protected
not just from bad guys but from flood
from freeze from fire too
head on over right now go check out the
award-winning ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles know w-l-e-s to get a great deal
on the ring alarm security kit today
that is ring dot com slash knowles
k-w-l-e-s
you can thank me later for keeping your
home and your family safe also get ready
for some laughs because the next episode
of adam corolla's daily wire exclusive
comedy series truth yeller airs tomorrow
it's really really funny adam mocks
hunter biden and the way our overlords
are training your kids and is joining by
comedian tj miller he is joined rather
by comedian tj miller head over to
dailywire.com
watch tomorrow dailywire.com
subscribe is where you can go use code
miller m-i-l-l-e-r
for 25 off your membership look out for
the new episode with tj miller dropping
tomorrow also it's true
right now
we are not only going into the media
we're not only going into the movies
we're going into publishing too dw books
we're proud to be publishing two books
that are actively fighting the left's
monopoly on storytelling the first is 12
seconds in the dark by sergeant
mattingly the book is the true story of
what really happened the night of the
brianna taylor shooting mattingly a
20-year police veteran takes his readers
inside his department's response and
debunks the lies that have recklessly
been shared with the public dw books is
also publishing fiery but mostly
peaceful by julio rosas who pulls back
the curtain and sets the record straight
on the blm riots that broke out across
the country in 2020
rosas who is reporting from the ground
gives his first hand experience at the
riots and exposes the media's attempts
to convince americans that the fatal and
destructive riots
were peaceful both are available for
pre-order now on amazon or anywhere you
buy books online we'll be right back
with a lot more
speaking of the russians
former house speaker and former
presidential candidate newt gingrich has
a really great idea if you ask me and
the idea is this if republicans retake
the house of representatives then the
members of the democrat january 6th
committee could find themselves getting
subpoenaed
you're going to have a republican
majority in the house and republican
majority in the senate and all these
people who've been so tough and so mean
and so nasty are going to be delivered
subpoenas for every document every
conversation every tweet every email uh
because i think it's clear that this
these are people who are literally just
running over the law
pursuing innocent people causing them to
spend thousands and thousands of dollars
in legal fees for no justification and
it's basically a lynch mob
and unfortunately the attorney general
united states has joined that lynch mob
and is totally misusing the fbi and i
think when you have a republican
congress this is all going to come
crashing down and the wolves are going
to find out that they're now sheep and
they're the ones who are in fact going
to i think face a real risk of jail for
the kind of laws they're breaking
that's the spirit whenever you want a
good pep talk whenever you want some
encouragement newt gingrich is one of
the guys to do it because what newt
understands is that you've got to fight
back you cannot have unilateral
disarmament
i don't want to live in a country where
we are regularly throwing our opponents
into orange jumpsuits i think that's bad
i think that's really bad for
civilization bad for our country
but if we're living in a country
where the left is doing that
we need to do it too
it's the only way we're going to get rid
of it if we allow them to get get away
with this sort of stuff with impunity
then
we're sunk
that that is no way to fight this is
this is what some of the squish
republicans
have suggested in the past they say well
we can't we can't fight back against
what the left is doing because if we did
that we would basically just become the
left you know like like if the left they
especially do this with wielding
political power they'll say if the left
golly if the left wields political power
to do evil things
and then we come around and wield
political power to do good things
why that would make us no different than
the left
um
i think it would make you pretty
different actually i think it would make
you the kind of the opposite of the left
because evil and good are the opposite
well if the left uses their political
leverage to peddle falsehoods and we
then use it to peddle truths we would be
the same no you would be different you'd
be the opposite because truth and
falsehood are the opposite
actually because procedure is not all
that there is
substance is important in politics too
and what newt is saying is he's saying
turn that january 6th commission right
back on him it's a preposterous premise
it is a vindictive
if an if not illegal
highly legally dubious committee it's
entirely partisan which is not in
keeping with the traditions
of our congress
so just get rid of it
get rid of it and go after them hard i
love that no unilateral disarmament
it's important in foreign policy it's
important in domestic policy too
got to keep up the heat great news from
the supreme court the supreme court has
just agreed to hear a pair of cases that
will challenge race-based affirmative
action policies
for college admissions specifically at
harvard and the university of north
carolina the cases will most likely be
argued next term
this is a really important case because
affirmative action is manifestly illegal
even
the justices who upheld affirmative
action the last time one of these cases
was brought to the court
even they admitted
it's not kosher you got to get rid of it
we'll deal with it for now because we
want to
engage in some radical social
engineering but
it has to be time limited that big case
was grutter v bollinger
and in that case sandra day o'connor
who was the swing vote who swung the
case in favor of affirmative action
against the rule of law even though she
was a conservative appointee she said we
are mindful however that a core purpose
of the 14th amendment was to do away
with all governmentally imposed
discrimination based on race accordingly
race conscious admissions policies must
be limited in times hold on period i'm
going to pause for a second she's
acknowledging that the 14th amendment
says no affirmative action
rugby's affirmative action is
discrimination based on race
and frankly the only reason these cases
are even making it up to the court is
because they not only discriminate
against white people but against asian
people too if they were just
discriminating against white people that
is perfectly accepted by the culture
that is actually encouraged by the
culture it's enshrined in law and no one
really says boo about it
but because the laws also discriminate
against asians which seems kind of weird
this is now going up to the courts
and
you remember the last time this happened
sandra o'connor says look the 14th
amendment says no affirmative action but
therefore we're going to limit it in
time no don't limit it in time stop it
now it's illegal so stop it you're admit
but no we want it to go on a little
while longer
this requirement of limiting it in time
reflects that racial classifications
however compelling their goals are
potentially so dangerous that they may
be employed no more broadly than the
interest demands enshrining a permanent
justification for racial preferences
would offend this fundamental equal
protection principle we see no reason to
exempt race conscious admissions
programs from the requirement that all
governmental use of race must have a
logical end point the law school too
concedes that all racist race conscious
programs must have reasonable durational
limits
okay
whatever the bogus argument last time
this came up 20 years ago
clearly we're past that time
or were right around that time at the
time sandra day o'connor said i don't
know about 25 years probably why i don't
know because i'm plucking that out of
thin air but that's why about 25 years
we got to get rid of affirmative action
we're almost there we're almost at that
time it's time to do it now is not the
time to go weak
you might think some of the squishes
will think look we're trying to overturn
roe versus wade maybe if the court
overturns roe versus wade then maybe
they can go a little weaker on
affirmative action and that'll keep
everybody happy
sort of like in the supreme court cases
on the vaccine mandate maybe if we stop
the osha mandate but we keep the health
care mandate maybe then everyone will be
kind of happy
well that that i think would have the
worst possible effect
because what the court wants to seem
like it's doing is not playing politics
but when the court is making those kinds
of
arguments it's completely playing
politics right it's simply saying we
want to make the republicans happy here
and the democrats happy here
which totally tarnishes the credibility
of the court follow the law
the law is relatively clear as clear as
it could be
follow it
even the people who upheld this stuff
say the law was pretty clear
and we need to make clear
to the court which reads the newspapers
that this is what we expect we expect
the overturning of roe versus wade and
we will not accept anything less
and we expect the ending of affirmative
action which is manifestly illegal
now
speaking of personnel
decisions we're talking about
affirmative action or modern
broadcasting neil young
neil young aged canadian hippie
well-known whiner of such songs as
helpless helpless old man take a look at
my life he's you know he's been around
for a very long time
not quite as popular now as he once was
looks crazier than ever neil young
is demanding
that spotify make a choice
it's either him
or rogan because neil young believes
that joe rogan is spreading fake news
about the vaccines this is very very
dangerous and so neil young says i'm
going to have you take my music off if
you don't it's mimir him it's not sort
of like a whoa boy i'm not i'm not it's
not quite
it's not my best neil young impression
but it's not that far off he says
i'll do this in my ordinary voice i am
doing this because spotify is spreading
fake information about vaccines
potentially causing death to those who
believe the disinformation being spread
by them please act on this immediately
today and keep me informed of the time
schedule i want spotify
to
know today that i want all my music off
their platform they have rogan or young
not both
it's a really tough choice
really tough choice for spotify
do you go with a whiny old hippie who
hasn't been particularly relevant since
the 70s or the most popular broadcaster
in the entire world
who do you pick
do you pick
this angry guy with admittedly like
seven or eight hit songs more maybe more
maybe that's not fair with a you know
dozen or so really popular songs or joe
rogan the single most popular man with a
microphone on planet earth right now
neil young i'm sure makes spotify
several hundred dollars a month
and joe rogan brings them in gazillions
of dollars a minute
i suspect they're going to go with rogan
that's what i would guess
part of the reason they should go with
rogan is that neil young is just wrong
on the merits here
joe rogan has spread much much much less
scientific misinformation about kovid
than has dr fauci then has rachelle
wolenski then has joe biden
all of those people
spread
misinformation
about
the masks about the vaccines about the
virulence of the virus about the risk of
the virus to other people about the
transmissibility about all of it
and the way i know that they've spread
misinformation
is that they have held
contradictory sides of all of those
issues
don't wear the masks they don't work do
wear the masks you need to wear them the
vaccines stop infection and transmission
the vaccines don't stop infection and
transmission the vaccines
are totally safe the vaccines actually
have some side effects and we're going
to pause some of the vaccines sometimes
the cloth masks
do work right they kept that one up from
the first and but actually the cloth
masks don't really do very much they're
nothing but a facial decoration that's
what the cnn medical analyst said on and
on and on and on and on
joe rogan much more consistent much less
misinformation than all of that
and the procedure is preposterous
for him to say it's it's him or me one
an important lesson in politics is know
your leverage no your leverage buddy
ain't nobody going to be missing neil
young i actually kind of like neil young
songs
okay i guess i won't listen to them now
okay that's not not a huge loss
plus i can listen to clapton and van
morrison who have a decent head on their
shoulders speaking of weird hippie stuff
the ruling class
really really wants us to eat bugs
they
they really want it this has become a
meme
people will say i will not live in the
pod i will not eat the bugs i will not
consume and and the ruling class keeps
trying to force us to do it they don't
want us to live in nice big houses they
don't want us to go to work and to our
community into our church into stores
they want us to live in a tiny little
pod in a metropolitan area and they want
us to eat bugs
from bloomberg
why bugs must have
a bigger part of the human food chain
they're fine for snacking but insect
protein
i like how they just assume that part
yeah sure they're fine for snacking but
we need to do more of that uh hold on
i'm a little skeptical of the first
premise
they write
quote humans have been consuming edible
insects from crickets and grasshoppers
to fire ants and termites since before
the dawn of civilization about 80
percent of the world's population
throughout asia africa and latin america
continues to eat bugs today
that's true
i think that's true
but
i think they're hiding the ball a little
bit
i think because i think the operative
word here is before
you're saying people ate bugs
before civilization that's true
and then we got civilization and
civilization's pretty great guys i
love civilization
i now what they're saying though is
even after the dawn of civilization in
the civilized world some places continue
to eat bugs such as in asia
and africa and latin america first of
all this is painting with a very very
broad brush
there are lots of people
who are
wealthy who have been
civilized to have interactions say with
the west who are in asia africa and
latin america who don't eat bugs but
it's true there are some very very poor
people
some tribal people there are many tribal
people actually in all of those places
who still eat bugs and who live in a
very uncivilized way
that's bad we shouldn't want to do that
i don't i don't want to live
like a peasant in the middle of some
jungle in vietnam i want to live like a
civilized person with the cultural
inheritance that our forbearers gave us
this beautiful thing that we are
squandering
but it's not look i'm going to continue
to do that i'm not going to eat the bugs
the bugs are gross
and guess what the people pushing this
mike bloomberg he ain't going to eat the
bugs
bill gates he ain't going to eat the
bugs all the hollywood celebrities all
the global political elites none of them
are going to eat the bugs they don't
want to because bugs are gross they're
going to eat filet mignon they're going
to eat caviar they're going to eat foie
gras and you you dirty rotten peasants
you're going to eat the buds you're the
bugs and you're going to live in your
pod and you're not going to own anything
and you're going to like it by golly
you see this kind of logic especially
with
climate change no now it's called
climate crisis
before that climate catastrophe before
that climate change before that global
warming before that global cooling
leonardo dicaprio
one of the
most vociferous
global warming alarmists in the world
he just made that that alarmist movie
about global warming called don't look
up it was
ostensibly about a meteor but it was
really about global warming as the
filmmaker and the whole cast admit
leonardo dicaprio speaking about the
movie he said i've had two great
passions in my life
that has been acting and the protection
of the natural world and getting the
message out about the climate crisis
okay he's on crisis that's the current
one
i've had a foundation for 20 years i i
got to go to glasgow i got to see world
leaders make some pretty substantial
commitments much like this movie
there is a ticking clock i think there's
a worldwide sense of anxiety about the
fact that the powers that be the private
sector the governments are not making
the transition fast enough we literally
have a nine year window
set your clocks
nine years that's what he's saying
now i guess it was only about three or
four years ago that aoc claimed that we
had 12 years so we're up maybe they're
trying to pick up an extra year there
but we're basically on track okay the
nine years it's over in nine years set
your clocks
that's what 20
20 31 i don't want to hear about it
anymore because then it's over there's
nothing to do
nine years that's all you get you can
run your mouth for nine more years and
whine and complain
and try to manipulate the public and
take all their rights and take all their
property and reorder their way you can
try it for nine more years but then i
don't want to hear it because you just
promised me it's over in nine years so
good it's over
now of course it won't be over they've
since at least the 70s really
end of the world predictions have been
going on since the dawn of time
but the modern environmentalist end of
the world predictions have been going on
for i don't know what but 150 years or
so
and then the modern version of it
overpopulation
global warming the ozone that's been
going on for about 60 70 years and they
every time they say we've only got 10
more years we've only got 10 more years
in the 19 early 1970s they said we've
only got 10 more years before there are
inevitably global famines because of
overpopulation didn't happen the
opposite happened the global population
doubled malnutrition hit an all-time low
but that's it thankfully we don't really
hear too much about overpopulation
anymore
they're trying to bring it back with the
weird bug stuff but that has that also
has more to do with the weather and the
climate and the crisis and whatever
my question for leonardo dicaprio is
you got to glasgow you got to go see
these global leaders make the
commitments
how'd you get there
how did you get to glasgow
did you
did you take a ship
did you did you canoe
did you
did you fly commercial even
no you didn't you flew a private jet
because you fly private jets everywhere
because you consume a whole lot of
electricity we're now told
that this is a bad argument no you can't
come on stop pointing that out it
doesn't matter it's like it's like
saying you're not racist because you
have a black friend
yeah that's a good argument too buddy
your behavior actually does tell you a
lot more about what you actually think
than some stupid
preaching that you give to news
magazines or on television
leonardo dicaprio does not live as
though the world is going to end from
global warming sorry climate crisis in
nine years he's not behaving that way
because he doesn't really believe it he
wants you to live that way but he
doesn't want to live that way
himself
the other lesson we got to take from
them
the left is always good at making
everything seem super urgent everything
always seems like a crisis and the right
doesn't do that we're pretty calm even
with abortion we're a million babies a
year being killed almost we just kind of
take it we're peaceful about it we're
very we
we're very calm we're very the left
doesn't do that
they're very angry
they get very they get in your face they
say the whole world is going to
end and actually sometimes the left is
not peaceful sometimes the left does not
follow the law i think we certainly
should be peaceful we certainly should
follow the law but maybe let's turn up
the urgency a little bit
maybe let's learn a little bit from
their rhetoric now speaking of adopting
the left's agenda really really sad news
from george will
george will is a
formerly conservative columnist he was
kind of the conservative columnist for
decades
and then he became more of a libertarian
in recent years and now he he looks
he looks somewhat liberal on a lot of
issues i think he may have voted for
biden could be right don't quote me he
certainly didn't vote for trump he hates
trump left the gop over trump
well now he's come out and endorsed
assisted suicide
assisted suicide
george will writes
the economist magazine true to its
classical liberal tradition recently
praised the welcome spread of assisted
dying for advancing a basic freedom that
is now legal in one form or another in a
dozen countries
and will it acknowledges there's a
slippery slope here and there are a lot
of risks that are coming around with
this such as i don't know pressuring
your old older family members to just go
on and kill themselves and stop being a
burden to you those sorts of things
making people feel like they're old and
energy useless and ought to just kill
themselves
because they're no longer
adding to the gdp and george will says
life is lived on a slippery slope
taxation can become confiscation police
can become instruments of tyranny laws
can metastasize suffocatingly however
taxation police and laws are
indispensable the challenge is to
minimize dangers that cannot be entirely
eliminated from society okay that's fair
enough
a grant that's true
all those examples he gives can become
they are on a slippery slope they can
become very terrible but they're
indispensable of society but this is a
really stupid argument because assisted
suicide is not indispensable to society
it's always wrong in the netherlands
just in recent years an old woman was
held down and killed against her will
because she had she had ascended to it
at one point and then in the moment when
they were about to kill her she pushed
back she was fighting the family and the
doctors held her down and they killed
her and then also in the netherlands a
29 year old woman did not suffer from
some terminal cancer some illness that
was going to kill her in six months she
just had anxiety she just had depression
some eating disorders and you know what
happened they let her kill herself 29
years old in 2014
belgium became the first country to
authorize children to request
assisted suicide if they suffer a
terminal disease or understand the
consequences of the act children
assisted suicide children have a moody
day
they have they go through some
psychological trouble they kill
themselves
at basically any age this is not
conservative
this leads to horrible abuses
this is not going to make a good
flourishing country
if you want a flourishing country if you
want to be able to project strength
abroad if you want to be able to have
strength at home
the basic thing is you need to not kill
yourself
okay you need to live you need to order
your society toward flourishing and at
the most basic level don't kill yourself
and when even the
nominal conservatives are pushing this
stuff you know we're in a really
really bad spot i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
calls peter ducey a stupid son of a
[ __ ] and the same media that screamed
about trump seemed perfectly happy with
it that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen